unfortunately cheating has been a part
of esports for as long as anyone can
remember whether it's screen peeking or
wall hacking cheaters are always trying
to get one over on unsuspecting fair
players but sometimes the ways they try
to cheat are just
weird today we wanted to count down some
of the most bizarre unexplainable
inexplicable ways that people have tried
to cheat over the years but before we
get into that i just want to make sure
you are all sub to the channel and if
you aren't already please hit the sub
button and turn on notifications it
really does help all right with that out
of the way let's get into it here are
the top 10 weirdest cheating attempts in
esports history
kicking off our list we've got former
hearthstone pro hosting in his match
against life coach at the pinnacle 2
tournament in january 2015 hostie
decided to try stream sniping his own
match despite there being a 10 minute
delay on the broadcast but what makes
this cheating attempt really weird is
the way he got caught after a few of
hasty's matches some hearthstone pros
like riparian noticed something odd in
the background of hosti's player camp
yesterday there was the pinnacle
tournament and in the pinnacle
tournament one of the contestants was
posted or ihosty or the former arkhan
hosti which you guys can see here and
the reason we're zooming in and the
reason we have all those arrow things is
because there's some reflective
image painting or poster or some [ __ ] in
his background that was perfectly
captured by his webcam which shows the
reflection of what seems to be seems to
be
um a hearthstone stream and a little bit
of detail on the hearthstone stream he
was uh seen in the chat at the time
hostie went on to finish dead last in
the event and was dropped from his org
the exact same day so remember kids
cheating is never worth it
in our number nine spot we have xqc's
version of the stream sniping scandal
back when people actually cared about
fall guys xqc thought it'd be a good
idea to stream snipe dr lupo in a twitch
rivals event yo you know what's funny
cheating and twitch rivals how funny is
that bro oh sorry don't laugh at it you
son of a [ __ ] i'm so you can win
together you're a star loser excuse me
and you have to stream snipe and hold my
members down you're losing what makes
this one particularly weird though is
that xqc had no reason to cheat there
wasn't that much money on the line no
sponsorship opportunities not even any
real glory it was just some friendly
games of fall guys in the end xqc
apologized for stream sniping but the
damage was already done twitch handed
him a seven day ban took away his prize
money and he was banned from all twitch
rivals events for six months what a mess
in our number eight spot we have a
cheating attempt that shocked the smash
bros melee community in july 2016 a
reddit user accused a pichu player of
hacking a console at a local tournament
to make the notoriously dog [ __ ]
character viable for once his method
running a hacked version of melee he had
created on a wii via an sd card
it worked and the pichu player began
taking full sets from power ranked
players with his bottom tier character
collecting prize money while also
generating some buzz once the tournament
organizers realized that something
seemed off with the character's downtilt
they decided to run some tests before
discovering that an sd card placed in
the wii had some altered iso files this
was the first time someone tried to
cheat in melee by literally hacking the
game so naturally it was a big deal and
since this incident teos have been much
more strict when players bring their own
setups to events
sneaking his way into the number 7 spot
on our list we have clash royale player
gregg empire77 during the red bull meo
finals back in 2019 the frenchman was
accused of communicating with his
manager mid match now given the clash
royale is a mobile game you might have
assumed that young gregory was simply
sending messages back and forth with his
coach from his phone but that's not
exactly the case you see once the match
ended and his opponent won greg could be
seen wearing earbuds underneath his
headset meaning he and his manager were
talking the whole time and somehow no
one caught the mid-match and they still
lost not long after that esl issued a
statement that greg empire 77 admitted
to cheating and he was disqualified from
the tournament
the number six spot is one of the
biggest scandals in call of duty history
back in june former cod world champion
kyler huke garland came clean regarding
his past adderall usage and shocked the
entire scene but basically i won champs
and i didn't really feel good
on the inside of course i was very
grateful for winning
it showed that we worked hard and you
know we got the win i felt good about
that but you know those couple days
afterwards i didn't feel good
and it was mainly because of one thing
i at the time was taking adderall
although we still don't know if adderall
actually gives you an advantage while
competing in esports the call of duty
league rule book prohibits the use of
drugs and alcohol which includes
prescription drugs like adderall in his
video hugh claimed that he and his
teammates were pressured into taking
adderall and that he specifically used
it while winning the 2020 cdl
championship cod's biggest tournament
he's sober these days but there is a
possibility that adderall gave him and
his team an edge despite everything huke
received a ton of support from the call
of duty community for coming clean about
his struggles with the drug we also
wanted to come out and make a little
video and say that we're really proud of
kyler for coming out and making the
video that he did
and there's there's
only happiness from our side that he's
actually speaking about the subjects
that he's speaking about and so we're
really proud of kyler
jumping their way into the number five
spot we have a bizarre combination of
international cheating and lame exploits
back in 2011 a halo youtube channel
called hidden reach started posting
videos of hiding spots and exploits they
spent years refining their strategies
and once the halo world championship
series was announced in august 2015 they
decided to put their exploits to the
test they entered the third asian
qualifier under the alias team meesang
despite not even being located in asia
something they spoke about on paradise
halo earlier this year for the team then
we had team meesang which is missing
and then
me neil i was ihlg
which was going to be hlg which stands
for hiddenly gaming which is sort of
just the community in halo that
hides in matchmaking for anyone that
doesn't know
then we had haidang
which is hiding and chitang which is
cheating
and then blue punch five which is
that's just blue fonts five team meesang
eventually fought their way to game five
of the semi-finals where they decided to
bust out one of their exploits live on
stream wow shout out to buzz lightyear
yes you are
i
so
is that is that even legal by the time
all four players were nestled in their
hiding spots meesang only had a one kill
lead but that was all they needed since
their enemies couldn't find them to
secure a kill the timer ran out and me
saying we're declared the winners
alright so we're still waiting guys for
a finalization of
what will be the judgment as team
meesang
defeats rock have fun in the most
unethical as well as is so disappointing
for tim meesang
they're really cheating me saying we're
disqualified by esl shortly after the
match but they honestly didn't care they
were just happy to show off on stream
shooting his way into the number four
spot we have one of the most infamous
cheaters in counter-strike history
forsaken the entry into the b-bomb site
doesn't go well
well that's a very long crazy spray
there for a second but he manages to
make it work now if you know anything
about cs go chances are you've heard his
name before forsaken was caught
red-handed at the extremeland asia open
in 2018. after some pretty cess plays
tournament officials decided to check
his pc and sure enough they found cheats
installed but what makes this story
really weird is that forsaken tried to
hide his cheating attempts by naming the
file word exe then after he got caught
he desperately tried to delete the file
before tournament admins could see it
but he was too late
now anytime a player does something
suspicious the word exe meme returns
in the number three spot we have one of
the strangest cheating attempts in
speedrunning history back in april 2019
an image of a 27 minute 43 second time
began circulating in the celeste
speedrunning community this was a world
record for the any percent category and
seven seconds faster than any other
runner the speedrunner who posted the
time phoenix 4k was a total unknown and
once other runners had a look at his run
they started noticing some pretty
strange things there was an image of a
bird in the bottom right corner along
with the words long live archie and also
no timer on the screen and according to
celeste speedrunner m sushi things only
got weirder from there the audible
portion of the speedrun was even more
bizarre
the game audio was completely muted and
in its place was a variety of grant
mcdonald's ram ranch music
i'm not going to play this music at all
here since it is incredibly
inappropriate but you might recognize
this music series for its iconic line of
18 naked cowboys
if you know the song you know how out of
place it would be for a world record
speedrun as you can expect phoenix 4k's
run was eventually deemed illegitimate
and additional guidelines were added to
the celes speedrun verification process
what a bizarre situation
in our runner-up spot we have a scandal
to turn the virtual cycling world upside
down yup that's right i said virtual
cycling in october 2019 esports cyclist
cameron jeffers was stripped of his
titles after admitting to robo-doping
zwift is an esport where cyclists can
compete amongst each other without
actually having to leave the comfort of
their homes as you compete more and more
you receive better bikes to use but the
ultimate goal is to unlock the tron bike
now jeffers didn't put in all the hard
work to unlock the bike and found
another way to the top bike instead so
you know this person logged into my
account used an amp plus simulator which
i don't know exactly how they work
because i've never used one myself um so
i can't honestly tell you completely
accurately but i think it's something
some sort of software on on your
computer
and you can essentially just put in like
a power value for example like 400 watts
click enter and your avatar within the
game will just sit at 400 watts about
like you having to pedal in the end
jeffers was struck with a 6 month
suspension and find 250 pounds
in our number one spot we have the
craziest cheating scandal in trackmania
history now trackmania has a pretty
small community but what's really wild
about this one is the con went
undetected for over a decade back in
2019 a polish programmer named donadigo
created a script to extract the inputs
from each lamp uploaded the trackmania
leaderboard this allowed other players
to watch back the replays and see every
little detail of how top players
achieved record time but when dona diego
was asked to take a look at a run from a
top player named ryolu he was a little
disappointed with what he found so i i
took the replay i fed it into my tool
and
i sent them the clip
and well i i was pretty
concerned
because
the inputs looked very strange but
at first you know it's real so i thought
you know maybe it just
some discrepancy in in my tool or
or
some bug in the game basically
ryobu was pressing inputs at an inhuman
speed so when dona diego sent the replay
to another track mania player named
virtual the two of them realized that
this would only be possible if ryogu was
using software to slow down his game
once donadigo and virtual did a little
bit more digging they decided to publish
their findings seven other highly ranked
players were named in the report but
ryolu still claimed as innocent what a
[ __ ] show
right folks that's our list if we miss
any bizarre cheating attempts you've
seen over the years make sure to let us
know in the comments otherwise thank you
so much for watching and we'll see you
in the next one
uh i don't know what's why it's weird
clara
hold on clara give me one second
clara
let me just message this girl give me
one second why is this on my computer
right now
where is this how do i